[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[BELL RINGING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADDY (SINGING): School's
out, school's out.
I love everything.
School's out, school's out.
It makes me wanna,
it makes me wanna--
wee.
[GIGGLING]
Oh, I love you, steps.
I love you, tree.
I love you, grass,
and parking meter.
Everything is sweeter
when I'm free to run.
I love you, shoes.
I love you, hair.
I love you, wind
and firefighter.
Everything is brighter
when I'm free to play.
ALL (SINGING): School's
out, school's out.
I love everything.
Time stops, dance, shout.
It makes me wanna,
it makes me wanna--
wee.
[GIGGLING]
RJ (SINGING): When school's out,
I get to build my rocket ship.
ADDY: Yeah.
[GIGGLING]
MELODY (SINGING):
When school's out,
I get to sing as
loud as I want to.
Ooh.
UNO (SINGING):
When school's out,
I get to do my math at home.
CINDY (SINGING): But the best
is when we all get to play.
ALL (SINGING): Play.
School's out, school's out.
I love everything.
Time stops, dance, shout.
It makes me wanna,
it makes me wanna--
ADDY (SINGING): Not
everything is perfect.
MELODY (SINGING): Mhm.
Sometimes we are teased.
CINDY (SINGING): For
simply being different.
RJ (SINGING): And
bullies are displeased.
UNO (SINGING): But
different's also special.
CINDY (SINGING): There's
weakness and there's strength.
ALL (SINGING): And kindness
makes a difference.
Kindness makes a difference.
ADDY: Oh, what's that poster?
Hm.
The 29th Annual Math
Mania Competition.
The team that wins gets a prize.
[GASPS]
A bike.
A red, shiny bike.
Oh, I've got to win that prize.
Uno could compete for
us and win the bike.
I'm going to sign him up.
He'll thank me for this.
A bike.
Ya.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL (SINGING): School's
out, school's out.
I love everything.
School's out, school's out.
It makes me wanna,
It makes me wanna--
ADDY (SINGING): Bike
ADDY: A bike, a bike, a bike.
TOM: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM: Clap for the cast
of "Addy and Uno."
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Are you guys so excited-- clap
if you're happy to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
I have to clap because
I'm so happy to be here.
Did you guys like that number?
Was it fun?
[APPLAUSE]
Do you want me to tell
you something super cool
about being here at Google?
The person who wrote that song
actually works for Google,
and she's right here right
now, Bonnie Gleicher.
[CHEERING]
How awesome is that?
Got a celebrity in the building.
Isn't that amazing?
So parents, if you want to come
bring the kids to the show,
see Bonnie.
She'll take care of us.
ADDY: Yeah.
TOM: So as you just
saw in the number,
Addy signs up Uno for the
Math Mania competition
because she wants--
first off, she wants him
to get over his fears
and accomplish things.
But she also wants a
red, shiny, new bike.
Do you guys like bikes?
Clap if you like bikes.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
And I love bikes.
I also love puppets.
Do you-- clap if
you love puppets,
because I love puppets.
[APPLAUSE]
You know what else I love?
I love jokes.
Clap if you like jokes.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
I'm going to tell you one.
I'm going to tell you one, OK?
What do you call
a broken pencil?
ADDY: Hm,
TOM: Pointless.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Well, as we've just said,
we're here at "Addy and Uno."
I am Tom.
I'm the producer of
this show, and with
me right now is one of my
very best friends, Anastasia.
[CHEERING]
ANASTASIA: I'm the consulting
producer on this show.
And one of the reasons why
I think a show like this
is so important, and
one of the reasons
why I would love it if all of
you guys tell all your friends,
and all your friend's families,
and come see the show,
is because when I was
little, like you guys,
I didn't have
characters on the stage,
or on television, or in the
movies that looked like me.
And I think it's really
great that the show allows
kids who are like me to see
themselves on the stage.
But it also teaches all of us
about how important kindness
is, and that's a message that
we think everybody should
learn and help us to spread.
TOM: Yes.
Big and little kids alike,
kindness makes a difference.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're going to do
another song for you.
At this moment of the show,
as Addy told you earlier,
RJ, he loves science
and he loves rockets.
And he just built the
most amazing rocket, which
makes me think of another joke.
Why did the cow get
on the rocket ship?
AUDIENCE: I know.
TOM: You want to tell?
You can do it.
AUDIENCE: He wanted
to go to the moon.
TOM: Because he wanted
[CHEERING]
Yes.
All right.
We're going to hire
you for the next show.
[LAUGHTER]
He delivers that better than me.
MELODY: Perfect, yeah.
TOM: But unfortunately,
it doesn't stay super fun
because the bullies take
RJ's rocket from him,
and they break it.
And I bet you, you
know, we've all
had a time where
someone's picked on us
or a bully's been mean.
And we know that is no
fun, and it is absolutely
the wrong thing to do.
So RJ's friends try
to lift his spirits.
And RJ, through the next song,
lets us all know that no matter
what, he's not going to
give up on his dreams,
and he can achieve anything.
And this is your favorite song
on the show, right, Anastasia?
ANASTASIA: It's my
favorite song in the show
because when I was
little, I actually
did think I could
fly in my wheelchair,
and I love that RJ
thinks that too.
And I'm really excited
for you to see it.
TOM: This song is
called "Watch Me Fly."
Take it RJ.
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RJ (SINGING): The easiest thing
to do is give up and give in.
The hardest thing to do
is stay strong and win.
But I just know I'm never
letting go of my dream.
Though people like to say
I'm too weak, I'm too small.
There's too much in my
way, I'll miss, I'll fall.
But I just know I'm
stronger than I seem.
Because I've got wings on
my back, fuel in my heart.
There are mountains to
see, clouds left to part.
I've got friends on the ride.
I know I'll reach the sky.
Watch me fly.
From morning to the night,
I'll work with the pieces.
Build it till it's right,
then test it, release it.
Because I just know I'm
getting closer to my dream.
And no one will
tell me what to do.
tell me what to say.
The day they watch me
rise and zoom away, away.
Because I've got wings on
my back, fuel in my heart.
There are mountains to
see, clouds left to part.
I've got friends on the ride.
I know I'll reach the sky.
Watch me fly.
Every single year
we read about all
of the greats, FDR, Frida
Kahlo, they defied their fate.
And every time I see a
star shoot across the sky,
I look at it and think
if they can, why can't I?
Watch me fly.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
TOM: Wow.
Thank you, RJ.
That was beautiful.
That was so wonderful.
Do you guys like rockets?
Clap if you like rockets.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
Not going to spoil
it, but RJ does
get a new, beautiful rocket,
and it's painted gold.
So cool.
Oh, look at-- whoa.
You have a rocket.
That's an amazing rocket.
RJ: That looks just like mine.
TOM: That's awesome.
Wow.
Well, we're going to do
one more song for you guys.
OK, and fine.
I'll do one more joke.
How do you get a
Kleenex to dance?
Put a little boogie into it.
Come on, come on.
[LAUGHTER]
Come on.
You like it.
Whoa.
Oh, OK.
So our last song
today, Uno really
wants to compete in Math Mania,
but he's still so afraid,
and he's very afraid that the
bullies are going to tease him.
So his friends get
behind him and tell him
that no matter what he
decides, that they'll still
be friends and everything
is still going to be OK.
Because no matter what happens,
you can count on your friends.
Take it, guys and girls.
ADDY: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CINDY: Uno, everyone
here is your friend.
Friends will love
you, no matter what.
MELODY: That's right.
We all believe in you.
MELODY (SINGING): It's a big
decision, there is no denying.
Uh.
It can feel like much too much.
Uh huh.
But you have got the talent,
what's the harm in trying?
You have got the Midas Touch.
UNO: Oh, I don't know.
MELODY (SINGING): Oh, you're
the best and the brightest,
strong, yeah, the rightest.
Always getting an A.
You're the toughest,
you're crazy genius inventions,
always ready to slay.
[LAUGHTER]
No need to be humble today.
So think it over,
can't get too excited.
And think it over and over.
Whoa, you've got
to stay laid back.
There's no need to hurry.
Take it from us, you've got
the time to think it over.
[LAUGHTER]
UNO: But, but, but
what about the bullies?
CINDY: Oh.
RJ: What about the bullies?
UNO: Well, if I make
a mistake or fail,
they're going to
point and laugh.
And then what?
[SIGHING]
RJ (SINGING): We've
all got our bullies.
They're a huge distraction.
Cowards who are insecure.
ALL (SINGING): So
insecure, so insecure.
MELODY (SINGING): But even
they have limitations.
Add them up like computations.
It's the truth you can't ignore.
ALL (SINGING): Oh, you're the
toughest and smartest, clearly
an artist, numbers
of colors you paint.
You're a cool calculator,
short formulator, always ahead
of the game.
ADDY (SINGING): You are
on the verge of your fame.
MELODY (SINGING): You are
on the verge of your--
ALL (SINGING): So think it
over, can't get too excited.
And think it over and over.
Oh, you've got the
night to sleep on it,
than you'll have your answer.
Take it from us,
you've got the time.
To think it over.
MELODY (SINGING): Watch
out world, here I come.
And think it over
and over, oh, oh, oh.
Over, yeah.
[VOCALIZING]
Over, ah.
ADDY (SINGING): End
of the day, we just
want what is best for you.
UNO: You do?
ALL (SINGING): We do.
We do.
ADDY (SINGING): And
at the end of the day,
we will always believe in you.
UNO: You will?
ALL (SINGING): It's true.
It's true.
ADDY (SINGING): No matter what
you decide to do, it's true.
ALL (SINGING): So think it over.
UNO: I'm in the auditorium.
UNO: The crowd is watching,
and the bullies are there.
ALL (SINGING): So think it over.
UNO: But I'm not afraid.
UNO: And it's our turn.
ALL (SINGING): So think it over.
UNO: We're given the question.
UNO: Oh, it looks hard.
ALL (SINGING): So think it over.
UNO: But I think I know it.
ALL (SINGING): You
think you know it?
UNO: I have the answer.
ALL (SINGING): You
have the answer?
UNO: I win the game.
ALL (SINGING): You win the game?
Yay.
UNO (SINGING): It's a big
decision, there is no denying.
I'm ready.
TOM: Yay, Uno.
He's ready.
[CHEERING]
Wow.
That was so much fun.
[CHEERING]
I want to introduce
you, all of you,
to one more person that you
didn't really hear from.
You heard from the
amazing mathematician,
Uno, the hilarious See See.
[LAUGHTER]
The brilliant Addy.
RJ has amazing rockets.
The songstress, Melody.
[CHEERING]
But we have another
friend that goes to school
with us named Kelsey,
who's new at the school.
She is also, like See See,
she's also hearing impaired.
And she knows how to do
some of the coolest things,
and she loves her new school.
And she's going to tell
you why real quick.
KELSEY: So I love my new
friends because we all
count on each other.
So can I teach you something
in sign language today?
ALL (SINGING): Yeah.
TOM: Oh, in sign language?
KELSEY: So I'm
going to teach you
how to say you can
count on friends.
So if you want to
repeat after me--
TOM: Awesome.
KELSEY: We'll learn.
OK?
You.
ALL: You.
KELSEY: Can.
ALL: Can.
KELSEY: Count
ALL: Count.
KELSEY: On.
ALL: On.
KELSEY: Friends.
ALL: Friends.
KELSEY: Do you want
to put it together?
ALL: Yeah.
You can count on friends.
TOM: Faster?
KELSEY: Let's do it.
ALL: You can count on friends.
[CHEERING]
TOM: Whoa, thank you, Kelsey.
That was so awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
And thank you all so much.
Did you have fun?
ALL: Yeah.
TOM: How much fun?
Did you have so much fun?
[CHEERING]
OK.
One more joke.
[LAUGHTER]
What do you call a
cheese that isn't yours?
Nacho cheese.
[LAUGHTER]
Because it's not your cheese.
Get it?
Because it's cheese,
but it's not--
joke.
That's the joke.
AUDIENCE: I have a joke.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: Yeah?
Do you want to come
up and tell me?
ADDY: Oh, cool.
MELODY: Yeah, yeah.
TOM: What's your joke?
Oh, using the--
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Who let the
poop in the toilet?
TOM: Watches a
poop in the toilet.
AUDIENCE: You have to flush the
toilet and put in your poop.
[CHEERING]
TOM: Yes!
[LAUGHTER]
High five.
[CHEERING]
I'm putting that
right in my act.
[LAUGHTER]
What we're going to do now is--
You're hired.
MELODY: Good job.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: So in a couple
of seconds, we're
going to ask some questions.
So in the next minute or
so, think of a question,
and I'll come out with
an elegant microphone
and we can ask questions.
And the cast, and Anastasia,
and even I will answer some.
And then we'll take
pictures with the cast.
But first, we just
want to thank you all.
Do you have a joke for me?
All right.
Think about it in one minute.
We're going to knock
it out of the park, OK?
MELODY: Yes.
[GIGGLING]
TOM: But thank you so much
to all the amazing people
at Google.
I love Google.
I Google myself daily.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sure you all do too,
so it's pretty great.
And the amazing Bonnie, who
brought us here and wrote
this beautiful music.
[CHEERING]
She's not here, but Dr.
Nava Silton, wrote the play.
And she's wonderful,
but she's at home
with the beautiful new baby.
Thank you to our beautiful cast
and all of you amazing people.
If you liked what you
saw, and I hope you did,
please come see us.
We play at Theater Row
on West 42nd Street
every Saturday at noon.
You can go to www.addyanduno.com
for all the information
on tickets and everything.
And kids, just this
once, I give you
permission to totally nag your
parents to make them bring you.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, you totally should.
MELODY: Do it.
TOM: Just-- but please tell all
your friends, because it really
is a beautiful show.
And I promise, kindness
makes a difference.
And everybody that comes
in and sees the show,
they leave knowing that
different is special
and that everyone is
beautiful, no matter what.
And you can count on friends.
And you want to add
anything, Anastasia?
Because you know once you
give me a mic, I don't stop.
ANASTASIA: No.
You did a great job.
We want all--
[LAUGHTER]
We want all of the kids to--
all of you to talk
to your friends,
and all of your parents
to talk to-- have them
talk to their friends
and tell them to come
see the show because we
need help to keep it open,
and we can't do that
if we don't have
people to come see the show.
We are also-- get the
community involved
to help us keep playing this
show, we started a GoFundMe.
TOM: Oh.
That is true.
ANASTASIA: So if you'd like more
information about the GoFundMe
page, you can reach out to us
through www.addyanduno.com,
and we'd be happy
to tell you what
you can do to help us fund raise
and keep the show open as long
as we can.
So--
TOM: And the goal of the page is
so we can cut ticket prices to
not-- so we can become not only
the most groundbreaking family
show in New York, but
the most affordable.
Because the families
who need to see
this most are being
priced out of it.
And we're going to,
through the GoFundMe,
create a campaign that puts
a block of sponsor tickets
on our website every week.
So no matter what, every
family and every child
can see "Addy and Uno."
So if you want to check it
out and tell your friends,
we'd love it because we
want everyone to see this.
ANASTASIA: And we also want--
we've had a lot of
people approach us
about bringing it
to the board of Ed,
but again, it's an
issue of funding.
A lot of schools want to
bring it to their schools
and have it be apart,
but they can't afford it.
So if we're able to raise
the money, then we can also--
TOM: We're going.
We'll go everywhere.
ANASTASIA: We can tour
the schools as well,
which would be really great.
TOM: Now it's the fun time.
Any question you like.
I'll even tell more
jokes, if you ask.
[LAUGHTER]
And you've been
waiting so patiently.
We're going to start with you.
I'm going to get
right down here,
because you're a
little taller than me.
[LAUGHTER]
What do you got for me?
AUDIENCE: Why didn't the
skeleton go to the dance?
TOM: Why didn't the--
what?
AUDIENCE: That was wrong.
AUDIENCE: Why did the skeleton--
AUDIENCE: Why didn't
the skeleton burp?
TOM: Why didn't
AUDIENCE: Because he didn't
have the guts to fart with.
TOM: Oh, he didn't have
the guts to fart with.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
That was epic.
High five.
Amazing joke.
So does anyone
have any questions?
Raise your hand, and I
will run over to you.
You have another joke?
All right.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: What did the
pirate say when you stuck
his wooden leg in the freezer?
TOM: What did the
pirate say when he stuck
his wooden leg in the freezer?
Go.
AUDIENCE: Shiver me timbers.
TOM: Oh, shiver me timbers.
Hilarious.
[LAUGHTER]
You're hired.
ADDY: Good job.
TOM: OK.
Does anyone have any questions
about the puppets, about
the show, about Addy
and Uno, about anything
to do with performing?
We're-- believe it or not,
we're super professional.
What about-- do you
have a question?
ANASTASIA: Remember,
all the puppets
can answer your questions, so--
TOM: The puppet can
answer your question,
the actor can answer
your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM: Yes.
I'm on my way.
AUDIENCE: Yay.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: Do you have a question?
You can tell--
AUDIENCE: What happened to Uno?
TOM: What--
UNO: What happened to Uno.
TOM: Oh, OK.
So what happened to Uno once
he entered the competition?
UNO: Well, you're going to
have to come see the play
to find out.
I don't want to give
away the ending.
TOM: We can't tell
you if he wins, but--
AUDIENCE: He wins.
MELODY: Hey.
[GASPS]
Hey.
UNO: Don't ruin it.
Spoiler alert.
ANASTASIA: I was going to say--
I was going to say we
can't give away the ending,
but we can say that
Uno is super brave.
TOM: He is.
We love Uno.
Oh.
I-- oh.
AUDIENCE: I have a joke.
TOM: OK.
You-- yeah.
We love jokes.
Laughter is the
music of the soul.
AUDIENCE: Why did the
chicken cross the road?
TOM: Why did that
AUDIENCE: 'Cause it
needed to get eggs.
TOM: 'Cause it
[LAUGHTER]
UNO: That was a good
twist on an old classic.
AUDIENCE: Knock, knock.
[LAUGHTER]
Banana.
TOM: Banana who?
AUDIENCE: Knock, knock.
TOM: Who's there?
AUDIENCE: Banana.
TOM: Banana who?
AUDIENCE: Knock knock.
TOM: Who's there?
AUDIENCE: Orange.
TOM: Oh, thank goodness.
Orange who?
AUDIENCE: Aren't you
glad I didn't say banana?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: I am glad.
UNO: Yes.
TOM: I'm so glad you
didn't say banana,
because I was like, why does
he keep saying banana to me?
ADDY: That was, like,
really good stand up.
TOM: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a joke.
TOM: All right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What do you
say to somebody when you
don't want to talk with them?
TOM: What do you say
to someone when you
don't want to talk with them?
I'm going to cry.
What?
AUDIENCE: I don't
want to taco bout it.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: I don't want
to taco bout it.
Nacho cheese.
It's all tied in.
MELODY: I love tacos.
TOM: So does anyone
have any questions?
Hi.
Oh, I love your ears.
ADDY: Those are so cool.
TOM: Hi, guys.
Sorry.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: How old is Uno?
TOM: How old is Uno?
ADDY: Uno's 10 years old.
We're all in the third
and fourth grade.
TOM: Wow.
ADDY: Of elementary school.
UNO: I have a question for you.
What grade are you in?
TOM: What grade are you in?
AUDIENCE: First.
TOM: First grade.
That's so cool.
[ALL TALKING AT ONCE]
Oh, four.
Very smart four year old.
ADDY: Well, you
have such maturity.
TOM: Anyone over here?
I'm here.
Do you have a question?
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM: How old were
you all, the actors,
when you started performing?
Brent, start with you.
BRENT: I was actually four years
old when I first sang on stage.
TOM: And he never stopped.
[LAUGHTER]
KELSEY: I was six.
VANESSA: I didn't start
acting until I was, like, 16.
So I was a little bit older.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: Awesome.
NOAH: I put on a big-budget
musical of "The Wizard of Oz"
in my backyard when
I was four involving
the entire neighborhood.
TOM: Yes, community.
[LAUGHTER]
AMANDA: I think I was
eight when I started.
TOM: Excellent.
CAITLYN: I was five.
TOM: All right.
UNO: Do you guys
like to perform?
ADDY: Anyone?
Yes.
TOM: Awesome, well, go for it.
Audition for shows.
It's the best way
to make friends.
Go for it.
Don't listen to anyone
who tells you can't.
You got to follow those
dreams, very important.
What about over here?
You guys have been so awesome.
Do you have any questions?
Did you enjoy my jokes?
[LAUGHTER]
I will take your silence
as a, yes, you did.
ADDY: Thank you so much
for coming, everyone.
MELODY: Thank you.
TOM: Yeah, thank you.
Who wants to take a photo with
the puppets and the actors?
CINDY: We have a
question in the front.
TOM: Oh.
I've got a question.
I'm sorry.
Oh, it's from my friend.
CINDY: Sir Red Google.
TOM: All right.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: You know, I'm doing
the play from like, "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory."
Whoa.
We're going to get
a golden ticket.
[CHEERING]
TOM: Whoa.
He's doing "Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory,"
and he's going to
get a golden ticket.
That's amazing.
AUDIENCE: We get to keep it.
TOM: You get to keep it?
ADDY: That's so cool
TOM: High five there.
Congratulations.
Oh.
That's high up there.
Any more questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I watched the
"Wizard of Oz" today.
TOM: You watched
the "Wizard of Oz?"
Today?
That's so random, and then
he said he did the play.
That's the coolest news.
All right, so if you got-- yes.
Last question, then we're
going to take photos.
AUDIENCE: What happened to
the guy with the wheelchair?
TOM: What happened to the
guy with the wheelchair?
Anastasia, why does
he have a wheelchair?
ANASTASIA: Why does
RJ have a wheelchair.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANASTASIA: Because
he has a disability
called cerebral
palsy, and it just
means that he doesn't
have a lot of balance.
So his legs work, and
he can walk, like I can.
I can stand up and move
around on my own legs,
but I can't stand up by
myself because I just
don't have really good balance.
So the chair helps me move long
distances, the same like RJ.
TOM: And just like RJ--
I will brag as one
of her dear friends--
it doesn't stop Anastasia
from doing anything.
She's a brilliant
Georgetown graduate.
She's amazing.
Some of you might
have seen her on TV
giving a prime-time speech
at the Democratic National
Convention for 22
million people.
ADDY: Yes.
TOM: She is proof that you
can do anything you want,
and that there are no barriers.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm lucky enough
that she's my BFF.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So let's take photos.
ADDY: Yeah.
TOM: If you want
to take a photo,
let's line up at
the steps, and we
can take fabulous photographs.
And remember,
www.addyanduno.com.
Yay.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Google.